who's your pick in this top four listen
I can't even pick one because they're
all so good they're all so different and
grow me listen [ __ ]
[Music]
eg on the red carpet for the RuPaul's
Drag Race Season 9 finale getting all
the Queens to recreate their favorite
quotes of the season favorite quote of
the scenes season Valentina
your smile is beautiful o valid cheetah
your smile is beautiful yeah stop her
later you're perfect you're beautiful
you look like Linda Evangelista you're a
model she can walk out there in a diaper
I know like Valentina your smile is
beautiful I had not even remembered what
I said when I had got home I was like I
know I said something to her I just
don't know what it is girl when I saw it
like people were like posting later like
oh my god I was so bitter she's so mad
and I watched it and I thought it was
hilarious song you can get it on iTunes
[Music]
Valentina your smile is beautiful I want
an ABC sitcom true I love that and I
also love uh Eureka can you shut up for
a second
your voice your attitude everything
learn that choreography so you got a
real soft could you shut up a second um
really yeah it was totally unexpected
but it was called for and there was a
loud cheer amongst amongst most drag
race fan bases cuz she just went on
rrrrrr stoning is for ugly girls and
haunts me it haunts me who's after
pepper man why are y'all actin brand new
we got to get out of here okay
peppermint aaaah
why y'all actin brand new booth at the
pepper man that that's my favorite it's
not even mine but it's about me so you
know hey don't joke about that uh-huh I
gotta plug my own
it's my one catchphrase so I'm gonna
make it happen